in october 2021 mp sir david amos was
killed in his constituency
and he's threatening me he's
killed he killed david
it shocked the country and raised
concerns about just how safe our elected
officials are so what security measures
are in place for mps and has sir david
amos death changed anything
attacks on mps are far from rare
in 2000 liberal democrat nigel jones was
at his constituency office in cheltenham
when a man attacked him with a samurai
sword
jones was seriously injured but survived
a local councillor andrew pennington was
killed
in 2010 labour mp stephen timms was
stabbed in the stomach twice by an
islamist extremist during a surgery in
east london he survived the attack and
is still mp for that area we shouldn't
use this as an excuse
to close our doors and not be available
to our constituents that would be the
wrong reaction
in 2016 during the eu referendum
campaign joe cox was murdered by a
far-right terrorist in her west
yorkshire constituency
in 2017 parliament itself was attacked
when a terrorist drove his car into
pedestrians on westminster bridge
then got out and started stabbing people
five died in the attack including police
officer keith palmer
after joe cox's death in 2016 operation
bridger was set up it offered mps more
advice about security when in their
constituencies and meeting members of
the public
and gave them access to measures like
panic buttons cctv better lighting and
extra locks on offices and homes
spending on mp security soared 2.5
million pounds was claimed for security
in 2016-17
up from just 170 000 the previous year
after sir david amos death mps were
offered extra security guards and the
terror threat level was raised to severe
the truth is mps are still vulnerable in
their constituencies because meeting the
people they represent is at the heart of
the job
i think in terms of levels of abuse
things are pretty bad and what scares me
and worries me is the fact that we've
normalized that
and as mps we've normalized it
social media has changed the lives of
politicians they are more accessible to
constituents but easier targets too
politicians have reported receiving
increasing amounts of death threats and
abuse online in recent years especially
if they're women or from an ethnic
minority background a study found that
female ethnic minority mps received 41
percent of all abusive tweets aimed at
women parliamentarians despite there
being eight times more white women mps
in parliament some have spoken out about
the threats they receive especially
online i think that social media
companies need to do much more or to
ensure that people are safe online and i
think because people think they can do
it without
it being identified as then people feel
more emboldened to say things that they
wouldn't attribute to their name if
people knew it was them that were saying
it ultimately it is a balance between
protecting politicians and protecting
democracy and each one of the uk's 650
mps has a very different view over what
security they do and do not need